Speaker 1: Let's see if we can squeeze
in another call. What about Cameron
from Seattle, Washington? Cameron. Go.
Speaker 3: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Nice. It was very nice
to talk to you on this Friday morning.
Speaker 1: Likewise. Did you
have a question today?
Speaker 3: Yes. I know that
you've expressed your interest in term limits
for Congressman, but what do you think about
term limits for Supreme Court justices?
Speaker 1: I am in favor of it as well.
Speaker 3: Yes. What? What? How
many years would be a good term?
Speaker 1: So one proposal I read suggests that
12 is a good number because with nine Supreme
Court justices, you can create a cycle that makes
sense overlapping it with four year presidential
terms. I don't know that 12 is actually the
number, but it could be. It was either 12 or 15.
Speaker 3: Yeah. That makes sense.
Speaker 1: That sounds reasonable.
Speaker 3: I had. Yeah. Sorry for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. Thank you very much.
And on that note, that does it for calls
today. I am never able to speak to everyone
and I apologize for that. But I will take
calls again and hope to hear from more of you.